When Watson receives a
question, the first step
is question analysis.
One of the things Watson tries
to figure out in this step
is what the question
is looking for.
This is defined as trying
to find the Lexical Answer
Type, or LAT, of the question.
The LAT is the word or
noun in the question
that specifies the
type of answer.
You should be able to replace
the LAT with the answer
to complete the sentence.
For example, for the
question, "Mozart's last
and perhaps most
powerful symphony
shares its name with this
planet," the LAT in this case
is "this planet."
If we replace this with
the answer "Jupiter,"
it makes sense.
Mozart's last and perhaps
most powerful symphony shares
its name with Jupiter.
For the question, "Smaller
than only Greenland,
it's the world's second largest
island," the LAT is "it's."
If we replace the LAT with
the answer "New Guinea,"
it makes sense.
"Smaller than only
Greenland, New Guinea
is the world's second
largest island."
Unfortunately, the
LAT is not "island,"
which would be more descriptive,
since the sentence with "New
Guinea" in place of "island"
does not make sense.
We can see in these two examples
that sometimes the LAT is very
specific, like "this planet,"
and sometimes it's very vague,
like "it's."
If we know the LAT, we
know what to look for.
However, in an analysis
of 20,000 questions,
2,500 distinct LATs were
found, and 12% of the questions
did not even have
an explicit LAT.
They had LATs like "it's."
Furthermore, even the most
frequent 200 explicit LATs
cover less than 50%
of the questions.
So to enhance the
question analysis step,
Watson also performs
relation detection
to find relationships among
words and decomposition
to split the question
into different clues.
The second step in Watson
is hypothesis generation.
The goal of this step is to use
the question analysis of step
one to produce candidate answers
by searching the databases.
In this step several
hundred candidate answers
are generated.
For the question, "Mozart's
last and perhaps most powerful
symphony shares its
name with this planet,"
candidate answers could be
Mercury, Earth, and Jupiter.
These are generated using
various search techniques.
Then each candidate
answer plugged back
into the question
in place of the LAT
is considered a hypothesis.
For the question about
Mozart's symphony,
hypothesis one would
be the question
with "Mercury" in
place of "this planet."
Hypothesis two
would have "Jupiter"
in place of "this planet."
And hypothesis three
would have "Earth"
in place of "this planet."
If the correct answer is
not generated at this stage,
Watson has no hope of
getting the question right.
Therefore, this step
errors on the side
of generating a
lot of hypotheses
and leaves it up
to the next step
to find the correct answer.
In the next video, we'll
discuss how steps three and four
score and rank the hypotheses.